so the health of the people trying to
save our health is of real concern so we
want to pause now to read a couple of
letters we received both them are from
the nurses in New York City they've
asked us to leave their names that we've
confirmed these are real and we want to
share them with you here's the first
quote I'm currently in isolation because
I was exposed to a kovat positive
patient 12 days ago in my unit right now
we are just wearing a regular gown a
face mask with our eyes and head exposed
we only have one thermo scanner for our
entire unit our isolation room is very
small about 10 by 12 feet without any
ventilation we do the entire procedure
face to face with the patient with just
a regular mask and gown even when they
show signs and symptoms of kovat 19 I'm
on my eighth day of isolation
experiencing coughing with a runny nose
pounding headaches and diarrhea I've
tried to call the hotlines that they're
giving to the people of New York to get
tested they just turned me down since
I'm not sick enough it terrifies me that
I haven't been tested because I'm
turning 51 soon and suffer from asthma
diabetes and hypertension what scares me
the most is what will happen to my son
it was a lifelong condition if something
happens to me my husband is also a
health care worker who works for one of
the biggest homecare services in New
York they are also not provided with the
necessary personal protective equipment
because it's still not mandated by the
Department of Health for all healthcare
workers to wear the proper PPE New York
City has a shortage of supplies and we
are not yet at the peak the situation
here is only going to get worse unquote
here's a selection from the second
letter quote there's about trip triple
the usual influx of patients being
wheeled into the ER many of the patients
are sent home without being tested
because they do not meet all the
criteria there's always a lingering fear
that someone we sent home might actually
be sick the hospital is restructuring to
accommodate the growing number of kovat
19 cases today about 80% of the beds are
being used for kovat 19 patients we had
20 cases last weeks and today there are
over a hundred there's a lot of pressure
because we nurses have a responsibility
to all patients and at the same time we
fear getting sick and getting our
families sick it's a very tense
environment right now in the past week
we've had a patient come in for non
kovat related procedures after the
procedure the patient told us they were
exposed prior to coming in and sure
enough they tested positive things like
this make all of us suspicious
on edge all the time the nurses were
angry because we weren't all given an
n95 masks until this week and we're told
they're not enough we put our names on
our equipment because we have to keep
reusing them we were instructed to keep
our n95 masks until they are soiled we
keep the n95 masks in bags so that we
can reuse them I'm always afraid about
cross contamination but we're not we're
conserving masks it's not ideal
unquote